[Music]
decorator's are one of the coolest
features in typescript we see them used
all over the place in frameworks like
angular mob X and stencil to help us
write more elegant code but have you
ever created your own from scratch if
not today's video is all about the
practical applications of typescript
decorators will look at a whole bunch of
different examples and will even go so
far as to implement an API that looks
similar to react hooks in angular and
will do it with only five lines of code
if you're new here like and subscribe
and you can find the full source code on
fire ship IO so what is it that grater
exactly it's just a function that allows
you to hook into your source code and
either extend the functionality of it or
annotate it with metadata so why would
you ever want to annotate your code with
metadata the answer is you probably
don't there might be some good use cases
out there but it comes more into play if
you're building something like a
compiler like the angular compiler for
example and you need to analyze the
metadata to do things like dependency
injection so decorators can provide this
metadata but they can also directly hook
into your code and alter the behavior of
it and that's what's really useful to
the average app developer because it
allows you to write abstractions that
are clear and concise but they're almost
too good at creating abstractions so you
need to be careful not to overuse
decorators it can be tempting to create
a new decorator for every little thing
but they should be reserved for logic
that's stable and that needs to be
reused frequently throughout the app
there are five different things that you
can decorate class definitions methods
properties getters and setters and
parameters we'll be looking at examples
of all these throughout the video but
basically the function that you
implement will be dependent on the thing
that you're decorating in other words
the function arguments required to
decorate a class will be different from
the arguments required to decorate a
method I'll be using angular for this
demo so we have some actual working
examples and you can see here I'm in a
component file and I've simply taken out
the component decorator and replaced it
with this frozen decorator basically
what we want to do is prevent this class
from being extended when you're
extending a class with inheritance you
need to be careful with decorators
because the inherited class won't
actually receive the functionality of
the decorator that being said you might
just want to freeze or seal the class so
let's build a decorator to do that we'll
create a function called frozen and it
takes the constructor function from that
class as its argument from there we can
just call object freeze
or object seal on the constructor and
the constructor prototype and that's all
it takes to build a decorator just one
simple function we can make sure that
the class is in fact frozen by calling
an object is frozen with the class
itself and keep in mind that this is
freezing the class definition it's not
going to freeze instances of the class
so if we create a new instance of the
class it would not be frozen so the main
purpose of this decorator is just to
prevent the class from being treated as
a superclass for example if we try to
create a froyo class that extends ice
cream we'll get an error and that's
because our decorator is making the
constructor read-only so that gives us a
basic class decorator but I think the
most useful decorators are four methods
and properties and I say this because I
actually use method decorators on fire
ship IO to automatically trigger
angular's change detection let's imagine
we have this flavor property and every
time this property is defined we want to
add emojis to the beginning and end of
it now I know this sounds trivial but
we're actually hooking into the getting
and setting of this property which can
be very powerful for example stencil Jas
has a decorator called state and it
tells the framework to re-render the
component if this property changes so
basically you can just run some magical
code under the hood without actually
having to change the way your code works
at a fundamental level you'll notice
we're calling our emoji decorator with
parentheses that's because it's a
decorator factory a factory is just a
function that returns the decorator
function itself and I generally
recommend writing your decorators as
factories because it gives you the
flexibility to pass in your own custom
data as needed every decorator has a
very specific function signature for
example this function takes a target and
a key as its arguments the target is the
parent class and the key is the name of
the property that we're decorating so we
can make a reference to the value by
calling the target key now if we want to
listen to changes to this property we
need to replace the value with getters
and setters that getter function is just
a simple function that returns the value
and the setter is also a function but
here we'll go ahead and console.log so
we know whenever the value changes and
then we'll also go ahead and mutate the
value with our emojis so now anytime we
change the value of this decorated
property it will always have these two
emojis surrounding it obviously that's
completely useless but I'm sure you can
find a good use case here the last step
is to override the initial property with
these getters and setters so we can do
that by calling object defined property
and call that on the target
key and then we'll define our getters
and setters in here if you're not
familiar with object defined property I
recommend checking out the official Docs
but basically it just gives us
fine-grained control over how a property
behaves if we go ahead and open up the
app in the browser we should see the
emojis appended to our variable value
and we should see the setter logged in
the browser console the next thing we'll
look at is a method decorator so let's
imagine we have this toppings array on
the component and then we have an add
topping method and we'll just go ahead
and use this method to push a new item
to the array but let's say we have a lot
of different methods in our app and we
want to make sure the user confirms
these operations before they're actually
executed so we'll create a confirmable
decorator to handle this operation for
us and I'd also like to point out that
decorators are composable so you can
stack them on top of each other and
they'll be applied from top to bottom in
our case here when the user clicks add
topping is going to bring up this
confirm message and the user will have
to click it twice for both decorators
that we applied there for this decorator
will actually pass in some custom data
which we do by creating the factory
function and then we can pass in any
custom arguments that we want the
decorator function for a method takes
three arguments the target is the parent
class the key is the name of the
function and the descriptor is the
actual function itself more specifically
it's a property descriptor because a
method is essentially just an object
property whose value is a function now
we're going to modify this descriptor
and then return it from this function
first we'll make a reference to the
original then we'll override the
descriptor value and make sure that this
is a regular function and not using the
arrow syntax so this will allow us to
run some code either before the function
is executed or after but in our case we
actually want to change the entire
control flow of the method will do this
by showing a confirm message in the
browser if the user clicks confirm then
it will be true otherwise it'll be false
if it's true then we want to run the
logic in the original function so we can
do that by calling apply and then pass
it through this context of the current
function that we're in and that's why we
don't use an arrow function here because
otherwise the this context would be
different so apply basically takes the
original function applies it to this
function plus the original arguments
then we'll go ahead and return the
result of this function but if the user
does not confirm the message then we'll
just go ahead and return null which will
bypass the logic in this function
altogether now I want to show you a
similar example with an accessor in
other words a
or a setter let's say we have a price
getter and it's responsibility is just
to calculate the price based on the
users input one thing you're not able to
do with getters is pass an arguments so
instead we can create a decorator to
extend the functionality so we can also
calculate a variable tax value with this
method in our demo we should see the
price updated with the tax included
every time we add a new topping to the
order the decorator starts out just like
the previous one with the same arguments
and returns the descriptor that main
difference here is that instead of
overwriting the descriptor value we're
going to override descriptor get then
just like we did before we'll override
this with a new function we'll start by
just applying the original function to
the new this context and then we'll take
that result and apply some additional
logic to it afterwards
in this case just multiplying the result
by the tax rate and then rounding it to
two decimal places now let's switch
gears to the real gamechanger
how do we implement react hooks in
angular now I'm being sarcastic and
hooks really aren't necessary in angular
and we'll still need to use a class so
they're really not the same thing but
they will look very similar if you're
not familiar with hooks
it's basically a function that returns a
getter and a setter when you update the
value with the setter it will rerender
the UI automatically angular 2 has been
able to do this from the very beginning
but let's go ahead and use decorators to
make it feel more like react hooks so I
have just a regular angular component
here and then I have two decorator
functions set up one called use state
and one called use effect the use effect
took will be used to trigger a
side-effect to update the document title
so the template will show the count and
then it'll have a button to set the
count and then it will also update the
title every time that button is clicked
so if we go down here to our component
this is how we would use the decorator
we pass in a seed value of 0 to start
the count and then we define the getter
and setter as count and set count so
that's our property decorator then we'll
also define a method decorator that has
this on effect method and this will run
in effect either when the component is
initialized or when any value changes in
the component so we're just duplicating
the same exact example that you'll find
in the react Docs
we'll start by implementing the use
state decorator this is a property
decorator so it has a target in a key
and the first thing we want to do is set
this property to the seed value that's
passed in through the decorator the key
is the name of the property so we'll use
that key to figure out what the setter
should be named we'll use some regex
here to take the name
of the property itself and then
capitalize the first letter and then
append set to it then we can define it
as a method that sets the property value
and that's all there is to it we just
have a reactive getter and setter now
let's move on to the use effect
decorator which is even easier angular
components already have built-in
lifecycle hooks that are similar to
reiax component did mount and component
did update so our decorator gives us
access to the parent object which
already has ng on an it defined as well
as ng after view checked so we can just
take the descriptor value from the
decorator and apply it to those methods
and that's pretty much it we now have
the same organ Onix as react to use
effect in angular when we click the
button you can see the value updates and
the title also updates in the document
head as well I'm going to go ahead and
wrap things up there hopefully you
learned a thing or two about type script
decorators and if this video helped you
please like and subscribe thanks for
watching and I will talk to you soon
[Music]